[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Sophie Anderson and I'm 16
years old I live in Brooklyn and I am
the national coordinator of extinction
rebellion Youth us
I'm Keanu I'm 17 years old approximately
half of my school around 200 kids we're
gonna be leaving after third period I
think that there's around like 30,000
people that will show up so I'm very
excited to see what will come out of
this
my name is Alessandra de bon I'm 15
years old and I'm a high school student
in New York today I'm going to school
then I'm gonna head down to Foley Square
where the March will begin we in New
York City are gonna be marching with
Gothenburg and demand climate action I'm
pretty overwhelmed but that's been kind
of constant over the last month to have
this day like finally be here it's so
exciting
alright we'll get a photo here what do
we want no I think the voice that we
have is youth is really distinctive it's
really raw and it doesn't see through a
lot of the BS the adult kind of get
caught up in I'm happy about today
because I know I'm gonna get out there
I'm gonna be in the streets we're gonna
be there we're gonna be striking for
what we believe in
you know usually a lot of people think
that the individual can't make a
humongous difference but I actually
think that you can it's always hard to
be the first person to make that step
once you have an example it's inspiring
and it's easier to follow someone
[Music]
my family is actually really happy with
my activism and with everything I'm
doing knowing that I have my parents
support is really important for me they
are learning about this just the way I
am yeah yeah it's great it's like all
the all the schools are meeting up
growing up in this generation people can
kind of dismiss you obviously our
country is extremely polarized right now
and I think that especially on social
media it's so hard to have a discussion
but when you're face to face with
someone and you have those kinds of
conversations it's so much more
productive we are at Foley Square in
Manhattan in New York City I'm gonna be
one of the emcees here which means that
I get to do first introductions guys
there are people every single direction
it's pretty crazy and look at all people
here do you think actions like these
forced people to listen if there are so
many people involved in a movement and
so many people who are striking for
something they believe in
then the partitions on the billionaires
will be forced to listen I hope that
this works or the world is watching us
and we're using our voice in a really
powerful way
[Music]